hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Killing Floor 2 with Lord
million seven seven seven what is we
good yeah a little bit hesitation there
but I think that was good I think I can
run with that one yeah I know it always
gets so hard at the end of it
well god I just run that corner to get
puked on equipment I don't know why he
decided to explode everything me I mean
it is really weird that this game
exactly the same as the first one just
better graphics I really thought they
would have added more you know yeah the
person I was shadow hunter Johnny Bravo
oh yeah
do you remember the mod for left4dead
that made the tank
Johnny Bravo by far my favorite one
mama What did he say when he was like
trying to smash people I can't remember
what there's like ones behind glass they
freaked me hello happened in the woods
oh hey no they wasn't cabin in the woods
like in your opinion it was like an SCP
movie nation of lots of things like that
you never saw a cabin in the was a hand
oh good yeah it's funny because it
starts out it's like a shitty horror
movie but it knows that and then it just
completely changes but you're not gonna
spoil but the ending is not the same as
the beginning yeah no no god I just get
so much better it's so great though
creepypastas and everything you're in it
so did you know some of the things in it
are like left for dead creatures did not
know that they're like Easter eggs
there's like the witch and everything
isn't it cool really
your weight so I can weld this damn door
yet are you running you're running up
against the glass like a freakin toilet
like a bird it totally tricked me please
tell me you were joking about that
because my joking
[Music]
totes big jokes Oh totes makes us gross
that's my slogan trademark markiplier
you cannot say it I said big jokes whoa
there are guys like there guys like
floating on the things up this song is
called ravenous disease I know I can
read thank you I'm just better than you
woah what at what at your flute shoes
you don't have a flute
unless you have like a crotch hair floof
then I would be really really impressed
you have a sloop that's amazing you have
like a tail serious condition I don't
think that's true I don't know enough to
deny you pity is what various asius hmm
I used to be in pre-med I would think
that I would know about that stuff but
apparently I don't I was in pre-med I
was I was a good video with it but yeah
you just got to make me feel sad and
then I thank you YouTube is so much
better
oh yeah oh you're dead right like this
which it was the best thing in the war I
missed the idea of college I don't miss
being I almost not finishing I'm naive
when I was in it like appreciate what it
was you were in it like last year you
graduated that was that that was a
different thing that was oh is it
different you you you
younger different reasons wait what
reasons are we talking here
I needed a degree in something oh of
course I did not want to study whole
channel managed these geysers Oh God
naked but you would be like them the
most energetic hotel manager on the face
of the earth
and then people immediately turn around
and leave forever yeah called you stupid
those if the city a bunch of [ __ ] that
you don't need yeah but not always like
I miss the college experience being
around all these people that wanted to
learn like engineering school that was
good because outside of engineering
everyone's Dussehra to party but in
engineering like everyone wanted to
learn and like pursue research stuff and
that was really cool
whereas now I just kind of want to be in
that environment for all I did it it
caught me for like a second you know I
was the first time I was in college and
I was doing music everyone was like
wanted to learn music yeah yeah yeah I
hate to take like physics classes and I
was like I ain't about that life
mm-hmm it's cool but it's complex yeah
well I mean if you're not going in for
theoretical physics or even normal
physics which people have normal physics
pretty much down so there's really no
need to pursue a PhD in that so it's
really no need for it my future was not
in physics it was in music and then all
the stuff I was learning was not music
yeah wait you still want to pursue music
yes dude what I wanted I'm starting to
pursue music really hard so like maybe
easily I used to be able to read sheet
music like for just trouble cause I was
an honors concert choir hey recorder Oh
anak tin whistle just Duchenne with us
Church church recorder of course waiting
us again I don't know about this it
seems like people know like for holy can
you wait I don't think the earth people
are real people so I don't think
[ __ ]
you should be singer Daniel could be
guitarist I do drums yeah dude I would
do it right now like seriously I'm like
you made joke but I'm dead serious it
like music is like my next pursuit that
I'm doing as a challenge to myself I'm
learning from Daniel what what do you
want to do though I just want to write
music like just overall just compose
whatever's in my head
because I got a lot of crap in my head
very vague things it is very big but I
mean it's like it's more of a
generalistic thing I want to write the
songs that I hear in my head because I
hear a lot of things in my head and that
sounds like I'm crazy but it's like I I
always had a love for music but I just
hated band and I hated playing trumpet
no yeah so I have in my head I can come
up with songs I can hear them and I know
them and I know they're really cool to
me and I feel like they would fulfill me
artistically if I made them but it's
impossible describe because if I knew
how to describe it I would be able to
write it down and that's what I don't
know so I need to like learn composing
skills and also take singing lessons if
you had an instrument that you wanted to
play what would it be broad piano and
guitar both of those pianists man yeah
well I mean it's just the understanding
of the harmonics putting your fingers in
the right place of course it's all oh
yeah thank you I got [ __ ] away from me
[ __ ] Jesus yeah you ran out of armour
therefore you got kind of screwed it's
theoretical music session for some
yelling yeah
no yeah it's definitely definitely
something that I'm gonna be hitting hard
and another thing that I got inspired
for my trip from New York by like I I
really want to pursue these things and I
just need the time to do it and not
playing games with a bunch of goobers
like
you know yeah well of course that's what
I got to defeat I got have not play
games with you guys thought I can let
you do what I need you I got is my ammo
now wait I need that no no I need it
more
mine mine mine oh you what mister oh
yeah I got a scalpel doctor you might
nurse do I need to show you up something
that you say acutely you can buy one we
should kicking us did we ever yeah and
who's in the labor kills again
wait I'm I'm doing okay
77 with a lot of assassins wait you
could never be a dude bro you sure I'm
pretty dude bro you're not Dulce yeah
that's the nicest thing you've ever said
to me yeah this is like a closed-off
room we could like have a last stand
around here echoes off what closed-off
room I have a feeling these are gonna
rain in from some it's closed off room
why did you want me to say that twice as
you said rim room oh closed off rim rim
aha oh now you're making fun of me now
huh
no just the way you say things oh wait I
don't understand why no one else from
Cincinnati doesn't say room
American it's like I'm my brother I
checked in with my brother he says room
two
I'm not well I thought it was like a sin
sin anything because that's where I
learned to speak words I've never heard
anyone else does that he say room hmm
maybe they just haven't experienced
culture like I have it explored the
world because maybe I learned it by
being a half Korean half German baby huh
maybe I being half Korean half German
you learn to say it doesn't feel good
when people make fun of the way I talk
[Music]
oh he's not he's not letting him through
the door don't worry it shoots tiny
bullets and really annoys him don't move
there you go he really is after you
you're okay wait you're okay yeah all
right yeah we're ready han slow oh
that's a big guy oh wait you're on your
own
what oh he's after me don't please no
please we got a big guy on our tail and
by honors he'll I mean he seems to be
mashing weights facing everybody this
SMG is not good because it's not like I
can't hit shoot people in the head yeah
oh go up there everywhere I could use
some hell oh I got a hill Jack I'm sorry
I take my okay I say I heal JA why you
gotta be such goobers where are you
where your armors gone what are you
doing I think were you were you bum
hugging those zombie wait how do you do
explain to me the horizontal Charleston
please
you put one leg in the air you put one
leg behind your back you shake your arms
around and then you lick your sacs yeah
I always thought it was like you put one
leg behind your ear and then you one
putting one leg where like a scarf and
then you thrust your hypnosis maneuver
that's what people in Charleston horse
oh you're definitely of course us of
course where it originated everyone
knows that yep I may be clear you put
your left foot in you take your left
foot out yes you put your right foot in
up around your dick and then you're just
playing with it
of course yeah you don't want to be what
would be that guy that'd be weird
yeah cuz everyone's in the room together
when they're doing this and it's just be
awkward you know yeah yeah put a
shakedown
oh that's it's always here I don't know
in this hole was a terrible fuss oh yeah
the cake oh I call this oh there you go
this at the highest you can go
[Music]
that's nice I can go we are so mad
I gotta get a falsetto though that was
nice thank you
we should Soviet sorta band we should
buy a bar we should buy a boat bar I'm
stuck I'm gonna die I'm still in this
hallway got the welt doors oh yeah
because we saw how to play the game we
were too focused on cake and that guy is
angry and big well the ocean only
explained how I was gonna die
yeah Hey look Healey grenades you're a
nice big lad what happened to my Healey
grenades did someone blow up my Healey
grenades another big guy oh Jesus oh no
come back I need to heal you is he dead
yeah he's dead come back here big goober
invisible naked ladies thrusting their
crotches at you yeah the big dudes with
non hands that bugs me yeah well they
have hands and they have like an
attachment that they just insert the
grindy and spin it in their crotches I
really have heard is very pleasant hurts
good on your taint Oh Harris good on
your skin on your taint
isn't your taint good for your skin no
it taint good it ain't good Oh am i the
pun master now oh yeah hey jokes they
really do thrust their crotch at you and
when it's in slow motion it's it's
slightly sensual i I don't appreciate oh
is that bad soft ass right now thought
I'm getting some hard it's not sound
good
I've got loss of taint you guys need
some taint I've got plenty saw a guy
coming down the stairs over there wait
Jim
I got great grades for days hit him in
the head
yes open mercy
did you ever see Starship Troopers she
saw a grenade right into his mouth and
then they blow up
troopers off oh god yeah it is
no one gives enough credit everyone says
it's a hokey movie it's great
which one troopers you've never seen no
movie I guess these are all on Netflix I
think just go watch yeah it is good
times it's really good times it's like
almost best times it's the best it's
best it's hard not life for for us it's
our not enjoying it you know we just
discovered we have beautiful high ranges
why do we always go to the yellow ranges
its caps lock caps lock yeah we're like
this you know my channel in one word
[Laughter]
wait have you ever seen the room no
where's the room no have you actually
ever seen the movie the room no Jesus
wait yeah wait seriously then that movie
you need to all of those rule oh hi mark
did not hither
I did not see we're all laughing having
a good time onions Easy's inside jokes
and you're just not since I've seen it I
should probably watch it again yeah I
mean I'd i me i watched it once and i
played the game well wait there's a key
you
no there's a game oh wait jontron do it
know it dude I'm not gonna tell you
about the game cuz I forgot that I
should play that game on my channel so I
called dibs I call dibs
oh because that's what we do when we do
you need to watch the movie first yeah
it's called like the room tribute the
room tribute ah see is on Newgrounds I
think John tried like mentioned it in an
episode Holly did like he voices inside
yeah I don't know like I think I just
took sound bites from the movie I'm not
sure maybe that game is nuts
the only thing is that you know I've
played it before so I know all the tips
and tricks well I guess I can just show
everyone what the game is all about then
cuz I know how to play it you show it
best oh yeah oh god all the naked ladies
oh you're not saying that right oh the
naked ladies I'm gonna stick my Mickey
in your Fanny something like that isn't
it
oh oh the double big guys this is not
what I wanted
yeah I was wondering what that roar was
roar well there was the streak of the
head and then there was the roar of the
her trying to heal you oh my god that's
sorry big guys okay so Brian don't run
that way alone oh they're my keys
they're my keys is that really what you
call a dick you know yeah what'd you say
like you're taking the Mickey I didn't
know cuz I was about to reference that
slogan and I didn't know that that was
how they were related yeah you're
pulling the me you're taking the mick so
you're pulling my dick are you yanking
me is that what it relates to
yeah yanking me cuz that's an American
slogan yanking me
we are situation here yeah hey goon here
I'm gonna throw down some Healey grenade
and I'm gonna try to come here he'll
good old
Bob I did I head upstairs oh yeah we
should run shouldn't we yeah I'm
following Boober Boober fell down I
didn't oh I thought you felt that it
looks like you fell down on my screen it
just can't blame me for thinking that
you felt down when you didn't know it
fall down okay he's going the long way
oh no you come back he's gone I'm stuck
oh he said I'm stuck there's ammo here
and goodness you want to know what you
sound like you want to know go
oh go so bad you won't even know happen
when you got your Irish up in you oh I
can't really do an Irish I can do an
Irish think drinking song Oh what is
that well that's just offensive hey why
you got to be so offensive to your own
people because I hate them late it
quickly all right I got time for the
boss right this is boss's boss okay I
got shotgun assault rifle combo let's
just hope I don't suck and I got suck
while you go down at least distract them
right that's a good idea hold off for
this well we're just gonna have to run
away from them so we need like actual
place to go I bought a flamethrower yeah
that's probably good whoo flame on
[ __ ] don't waste all your ammo there
so boss hello German dude yeah he
doesn't sound German he said to think of
it he didn't say to take her bath he did
no one says to tinker with
the Germans do do not say to tinker with
tinker is also a bad thing for you think
to stuff a bunch of German people
walking down the street German chappies
just Auto tinker with is that what
you're thinking
yes 100% exactly yes I hear oh there is
he's poison yes oh he got a cloud he
hurts oh my go I hope it's hurting you a
lot I don't know I'm shooting them from
behind I guess of his greens greens do i
if I shoot him on his green thing in the
back
does that hurt him more I don't know
actually maybe how about some shotguns
it really pissed them off when I saw
them in the green tank run run run yeah
shoot the tank thank you I think your
father's realizing the gas you're on
your own yeah oh no we're not okay
oh he's up
that's as manly as I can get man I wish
they could do like they've really
cultural female screeches oh god there's
like things only women can do yeah well
I know if you actually you know I take
that back that's price sexist to me to
say I didn't even think about that we've
had plenty of guys that can do that just
fine you don't wanna go down that rabbit
hole yeah I'm probably gonna die after
this
he's I'm trying not to I'm in a corner
he's given me this team okay ow ow ow
I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead oh god oh god oh god I'm trying oh
who are you okay I'm dead
well well that sucked
we were doing fine yeah until the end
there we're like going after the little
guys instead of him uh and then you guys
walked right in the poison like a bunch
of goobers we're saving you from the
gravity grabs I love you guys yes I love
everyone out there who is watching us I
love all of your faces I just wanted to
say thank you for this experience of
being killing floor it really means a
lot to me if you want to go back in time
and see us when we were young and
innocent I didn't know what at the game
not even good at the game use the volume
mixer yes just look back on Wade's
channel yeah that's where it all started
and then check out Jack's channel we got
a large user and we actually won this
one we drank oh yeah
here
[Music]